doctor
i let you go
we have arrived at the final outing for
peter capaldi's 12th doctor twice
upon a time i really wasn't sure what i
was going to think of this one
my memory was that it felt unnecessary
and kind of vestigial compared to how
things
wrapped up in the doctor falls but at
the same time not actually
bad it didn't undercut or undo
or undermine any of the strengths
of the dr falls other than just the
nature of
prolonging the regeneration and while
the story it told wasn't
amazing it wasn't bad and it touched on
some nice themes some nice moments
and it felt it felt
okay and having now re-watched it yeah
basically the same
it really does not feel like the true
proper end what it feels like it feels
like a coda
it really does feel like to me at least
that the doctor falls is the
end of capaldi's run
and this is honestly you know what it is
a little bit
you know how the uh last
15 20 minutes or so of
uh journey's end from series four
gets really wrapped up in touching base
with everybody
saying the goodbyes like really properly
wrapping up the era
it feels a bit like that except instead
of being tacked on to
to the story um that really feels like
the end of the doctor's story it
kind of gets its own thing and then gets
padded out with this new additional
material
and that's not necessarily a knock i
think all things considered
if your choices are either
have a really stalled and delayed
tail end to your episode proper or have
kind of a laid back let's wrap
everything up
episode after your climax i honestly
think that second choice is
usually the better out of those two if
those are the only two options you've
got
i'm not sure that you could argue those
were the only two options but
like between those i kind of like this
better
and it does do some interesting things
and it does
ponder some questions and reinforce some
themes that
work quite well
at the same time it's got some stuff
going on that is just kind of
there it's like it's not bad
but it's like okay
the very presence of the first doctor
honestly
doesn't add a ton now i say that based
on the scripts
david bradley playing the first doctor
he's quite good at it
so like i i can go with that and
people have asked me in general about
the idea of
um having newer actors
you know recast to play previous
versions of the doctor
like look the only reason i give a pass
to david bradley
is because he was established in
uh an adventurous space and time where
he in fact played william
hartnell and so like sort of
springboarding off of that
into letting him have one appearance
here like i'm okay with that but the
idea in general like
further down the line of just having
other actors play
the second or the third doctors honestly
i think it's kind of gross
and and even this one like it kind of
pushes the border for me but like
since it's backdoored in i'm okay with
it and like i said david bradley is
quite good in the part there are some
odd things about the first doctor's
appearance uh the first being that they
have to kind of crowbar in this entire
idea
that he doesn't really want to
regenerate i will not change
i will not no no no the whole thing's
ridiculous
in order to try and link him more with
the 12th doctor because that was not
something that was in evidence at all
uh when the first doctor did originally
generate i do like the way the episode
opens like with
actual footage from of the 10th planet
and then colorizing it and switching
over to david bradley
i thought that was pretty well done i
suppose kind of the elephant in the room
if we're going to talk about the first
doctor
in this though is the very
outdated view of gender roles that he
appears to have
if you like ladies made of glass well
aren't
all ladies made of glass in a way
very good here's why that bothers me
i don't necessarily have a problem with
the idea that this doctor is kind of
outdated in his thinking
i mean the guy's 1500 years old
that's plenty of time to get a better
sense of things and like to pretend
that the era that he came from and some
of the things
expressed in the time when hartnell was
in the part
sometimes even occasionally by the
doctor himself as well-meaning as they
often were
could be a little bit by today's
standards so i don't necessarily have a
problem
on paper here's why it really bothers me
and i don't think it works as a
recurring
beat the first is it's
pretty much played for comedy every time
and i don't
find that funny like i just don't
oh look this person's got really
uh outdated and kind of narrow-minded
views on people isn't that funny i'm
like no
actually that that's i don't think
that's funny um
i'm not necessarily offended by it but
like i don't see why that's
funny um so that's the first problem but
even if you
do think those jokes are funny there's
still another problem which is that
the ways in which his views on gender
roles are brought up
are very crowbared in they never arise
organically out of the situation
the writers have to come up with stuff
like he's noting how dirty everything is
so we can mention
paulie must not be here in other words
there isn't
a woman to keep everything clean like
there's a setup there's a
prompt for him to say that but it's
manufactured by the writers
and these lines feel very crowbarred in
so that we can make
a joke and be like haha isn't the past
kind of awful and
like it doesn't help
it doesn't add anything and it's just
kind of groan worthy
to me and it's just very clumsily done i
don't really care for those moments
despite liking
david bradley in the part um
mark gaidis i i'm glad that they brought
him in to play
the the captain captain lethbridge
stewart
um if i have my math right on the time
this would be the brigadier's
grandfather and um
he's it's quite nice i mean because
prior to this we were stuck with him
playing
dr lazarus in the lazarus experiment uh
and i like mark gates actually i like
him a little bit more as an actor than a
writer
kind of frequently although he he can
write well it's just most of the stuff
that he's written that i really like
isn't uh doctor who proper episodes i
mean he did write a venture in space and
time which is great
but i i think he does a really good job
in this part
capturing that sort of you know knuckle
down in the trenches get the job done
mentality
but also the circumstances under which
that
mentality in that headspace that has
kept him alive up to that point
cracks and the fear shows
and how someone like that would respond
knowing that it's cracking a little bit
he's he's uh
he's a very well-rounded character i i
enjoy him quite a bit
it's hard for me to completely nail down
why i really like this
but with testimony the glass people
uh and this whole thing of basically
freezing time at the moment of someone's
death and
downloading all their memories
i really like that the doctor goes in
assuming it must be sinister
and finding out that it's just exactly
what it says it is
it is just a preserving of the memory
of everyone and even
he even says you know i don't know what
to do when it's not an evil plan
and i kind of like that especially
that the whole thing with him at the in
in the dr falls was i do what i do
because it's
kind and that gets reinforced here
that it he's not the only kind thing in
the universe and that gets reinforced
in two ways one by realizing that the
testimony
is not some evil plan
it's just a kindness so that people are
not forgotten
and they can be sort of recalled again
for so far as we see purely altruistic
and record keeping purposes so that no
one is ever forgotten
that's kind and two
the christmas armistice and adjusting
the timeline so that
when they drop the captain off it's just
a little bit later than it was
when he vanished and they fudged time
just a little bit
so that the christmas armistice begins
and he doesn't die and
the doctor the capaldi's doctor pointing
out
never happened again but
this one time in a war at christmas
people were kind and
i think that does a lot with sort of
putting both doctors a bit more at ease
with
their impending regenerations because
you know david bradley was starting to
get nervous just seeing what the 12th
doctor was you know for the superficial
reasons like he didn't like the
sunglasses
and the tardis redesign but for more
substantive ones seeing him address this
and being very concerned about what
what is he going to do with his future
but seeing him do that extra bit
go that extra mile to be kind to the
captain and to even sort of
recontextualize the idea of what doctor
of
war means because i mean at this point
we have had in the show
the war doctor and that's kind of where
your head goes
but through the crystal christmas
armistice
and in this battlefield where people are
singing it brings a new idea someone who
is
healing amid war
as opposed to someone who is simply
bringing
war and using the title of the doctor
that's that's really nice and having
a situation where you know the plot
that he uncovers is a kindness
and that he uses a renowned moment of
human kindness in the middle of horror
to save a man's life reaffirms him that
as much as he is running around trying
to right so many wrongs
there is other kindness there is
kindness elsewhere in the universe
he's not the only one being kind
and i think that feels to me like it
does a lot to sort of ease his mind and
calm him
with the idea of actually regenerating
and i like his speech
a lot i think it does a
great job re-emphasizing
those ideals that already did get a very
good re-emphasis
in the dr falls hate is always
foolish love
is always wise
love heart
run fast
be kind it's a wonderful
thing for him to go out on and letting
go and just
trusting because that was a huge part of
his hesitation at the end of the
previous episode
he'd worked so hard to become the man
that he was
he was afraid to change
but then on his last outing encountering
his younger self
encountering bill sort of again
gnardle remembering clara and
seeing the kindness that is
testimony and seeing the kindness of the
armistice
that maybe he can allow himself to trust
that it's worth going another round i
think it
it works as a coda it's not especially
strong as a standalone story
but as a coda as just a little
little re-emphasis little reprise
of things in a less heightened
less everything's about everybody's
about to die
situation than the dr falls was
and it does work
i'm still kind of of the mind that it's
not really necessary
and i think the dr falls might have been
stronger
without it but it doesn't
it doesn't annoy me and it should given
how strong the doctor falls is
in the idea of going another episode
after that like why
it was so strong but like it no it still
does work
despite some oddities so like another
one is
the bringing back of rusty the dalek
from
into the dalek which i mean on the one
hand is kind of neat
like i like that there was a follow-up
to that it's weird having it kind of
built up and showing up in this very
last episode
especially considering that was two
series ago
and was never really brought up again
it's it's it's like it's an interesting
callback but at the same time it's a
weird callback i don't know i've kind of
mixed on that one
and i did like the use of testimony to
have goodbyes
for bill and nardal
and yes even clara
because clara matters to the doctor
and him getting to remember her again
and the smile on his face when the
memories come back
is really sweet and i do
i do like that i do enjoy it
and that's just kind of where i'm at
with this
it's an odd little episode that doesn't
really hold up on its own
but it's it's a gentle
end as opposed to the
slightly more bombastic and that the dr
falls would have been
and while i don't think this is anywhere
near as good as the doctor falls
it's still pretty good
twice upon a time have you rewatched it
lately
what did you think about it whatever
your thoughts are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it i have
a patreon
that is how i pay my bills and there are
rewards for every tier of support
from access to a patreon exclusive
discord name the credits and
other things there's also youtube
memberships if you want exclusive emojis
and things for the comments or if you
make the live premieres of certain
videos
and things like that even if you can't
like share subscribe help me battle back
the algorithm
with its sinister agenda of just
not letting people see my stuff but
you don't even have to do that because
at the end of the day
you're the council i'm just running the
meetings
and until next time
laugh hard run fast
be kind
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
bye